Luke here with the outro Boys YouTube
channel for the next 4 days I'm alone
here in the Alaska mountains I'm taking
my snow machine deep into the Wilderness
I'm going to be camping in a hot tent
hunting ice fishing and a lot of things
will go wrong but I'm all by myself so
I'm just going to deal with
[Music]
it
[Applause]
[Music]
is a big
wolf
it's all moose tracks the Moose like to
come along and eat the Willows this is a
moose bed the Moose will sleep down here
they kind of just lay down on their legs
make a little hole there's usually a
pile of poop at the bottom about three
or four moose spent the night
here I made a wrong turn and I'm having
to backtrack about 5
miles not a lot of sun left it's going
to be dark
soon
looks like it's a good thing I turned
around I lost my ice
scoop oh my map says the trail is off
that direction but there's no broken
trail over there it's a little late in
the day to just start plowing off into
the forest I think I'm going to go that
direction and see if I can't find the
trail from another angle
well I think that's the trail but man
I've blown a lot of time Sun's going to
set any minute
[Music]
now well that's not
great
[Music]
[Applause]
o
oh man my snowshoes are gone the bungee
cords are gone and so are my snow
shoes I've had those snowshoes for years
I'm really sad to lose those but not
just that they're an important piece of
safety equipment something happens and I
have to walk out of here I'm going to
really want those snowshoes man I don't
know about
[Music]
this got to get this thing up that hill
I think it's best if I put the camera
down and use both hands moments later oh
boy I just instantly got stuck
again all
right problem with the snow is that
there's layers there's powder on the top
then there's chunky icy stuff and then
there's powder underneath that the snow
machine rests very nicely on the chunky
later but if you break through that you
sink down and it's it's really hard to
get out I am so
tired it's about 3° fah right now it's a
little
nippy
is
[Music]
there we go got it
done oh it's pretty late I was hoping to
have my tent set up hours ago but uh
found this shallow frozen lake I'm going
to go ahead and set my tient up right
here I'm setting up my tent on this
frozen lake for two very specific
reasons one I'd like to do some ice
fishing though I have no clue whether
this lake has any fish in it but more
importantly the snow is only a few
inches deep the snow is almost 4T deep
up on that hill but out here on the lake
where the wind blows it's only 2 in deep
it's about an hour and a half of
shoveling I don't have to
[Music]
do it's about 0° fah and handling these
metal poles is not
fun when it gets really cold like this
plastic gets stiff just opening up the
rain fly is a major pain in the butt
all
come
on I think snow got into the air intake
and now there's water in the
engine
I forgot to pack my handsaw and my
chainsaw won't start so I can't cut
firewood without a stove I can't melt my
water all my water's frozen I am I am so
thirsty today and then getting stuck
just killed all my time too many things
have gone wrong so I'm just going to
leave the tent and all my gear here and
I'm going to head back to the car I'm
going to come back and try this
again let's get
going
oh my
snowshoes yes oh I'm so
glad all right guys I made it back to
the car and maybe just maybe tomorrow
will be a better day I ended up getting
back home a little after midnight last
night and I spent this morning working
on that chainsaw
but I think I've got it fixed we'll see
I'm not 100% sure what happened to this
chainsaw but my best guess is that all
the snow and frost that was kicked up by
the snow machine got into the air filter
so I'm going to put the chainsaw in a
garbage bag to try to keep that from
happening
well looks like everything's as it
should be wind didn't blow it away
wolves left it alone I'll call that a
wind this is heat resistant silicone you
put it underneath the stove to keep from
burning up your floor if you're on a hot
hard flat surface you don't absolutely
need this thing but as the stove gets
hotter and hotter the legs melt down
into the snow and the stove gets closer
and closer to the
floor time to go get some
firewood there's a nice big dead tree
right there going to need the snow shoes
you got to be so careful with your tools
in this snow everything can disappear in
a heartbeat if you just drop
[Music]
it I think my theory is right I just had
snow in the air
[Music]
[Applause]
intake
[Music]
I want to get the snow machine as close
as I can to the tree so I can load it up
but once it's full of all that wood I
don't want it to seek in the snow so I'm
going to make a trail with my snowshoes
and run the snow machine up and down it
a few
times
[Music]
all right we got firewood yay I'll tell
you what I feel so much better than I
did yesterday it was totally the right
call to go home every muscle in my body
was soared I was dehydrated it was just
time to call it disasters rarely happen
because one thing goes wrong it usually
happens when a whole bunch of things go
wrong that's what was happening
[Music]
yesterday
I brought a few carob High to keep me
extra warm so will be really
nice all right going to make a little
torch here got a little bit of cotton
right
there there we
go get that right in where it needs to
be oh oh starting to get warm in here
this is nice well now that I got the
stove going I got a lot of things to th
out including my gun the gun got dropped
in the snow and it got all this ice in
the barrel so I'm just going to hang it
up here where it's nice and warm all
that water can drip out as it
melts I have no idea if there's any fish
in this Lake but I'd like to
try
[Music]
all right the sun's starting to set and
I got to tell you I'm exhausted I am
still really sore from yesterday I got
my snow machine stuck three times on
that same hill yesterday and it took me
two hours to get out
all right yeah guns looking
good all right I think it's time to do
some ice
fishing I don't know what's in this Lake
but uh I'm guessing there's gring and
bourett and bourett are kind of like a
northern catfish they behave like a
catfish and you catch them like a
catfish so so I got a little bit of
Herring right there on the rig we're
going to see if any bourb around help
tell us how deep this is it's pretty
shallow here there's only about 2 ft of
water underneath this ice when you're
ice fishing you don't need to go deep
fish will often be really shallow well
there we go we got a little bite alarm
set
up so we get any bourb it we'll know
about it all right just going to wait
for a bite my back is killing me I think
I need a
chair oh that feels good to say my back
is sore is a gross understatement I
brought a soda along to drink and it
froze solid it's a local soda this
flavors spruce tip we're going to we're
going to see if we can't thaw it out a
little
bit we're going to make some herbal tea
here I use the rest of the boiling water
to Tha out my water
bottle all right I think it's time to
start making dinner I was thinking
country fried steak sounds really good a
peanut oil
here got some very Frozen
potatoes great way to test oil to see if
it's hot enough put a piece of wood in
it it's Fizzles it's
good
woohoo
woooo hey my soda thought out going to
try to enjoy what's left of it that's
good kind of reminds me of seven up with
a hint of pine well to go with a country
fried steak I'm going to make a knockoff
version of Mexican street
corn okay so I've got some tajine going
to put that in there
mayonnaise
there we go I made a bunch of gravy
earlier and I vacuum sealed and froze it
so now all I got to do is just lay it by
the stove and let it thaw
out there we go not a bad little meal I
didn't quite do the country fried steak
right I forgot to bring the buttermilk
to make the batter but uh so I just
rolled it in flour and give it a go
still tastes really good oh I'm hungry I
missed lunch
today all right good got some leftover
steak I'm going to put it in the
freezer there we go I think I want to
have some bread in the morning I'm going
to go ahead and make some dough up oh my
bag's got some holes in it I got to be
careful just going to stick this up here
where it's nice and warm and that'll
rise all right I think I need to go do
some dishes it's going to be
cold all right I think it's time for
some dessert I'm going to make some
cookies beon Turtle Delight cookies man
this sounds
[Music]
good there we go we'll just pull them
over here to cool that shouldn't take
long oh not too
[Music]
bad that is good woring cookies on a
camp out and hard to beat if you burn
the him just eat him burn side
up all
right so I'm going to go to bed and I
will see you guys in the morning oh good
morning oh it took me a long time to get
to sleep last night I'm
tired okay I love my Caribou rugs but
they shed they shed like
crazy ice Vision with a bit of a bust
didn't get a single bite but I'm not
even sure there are any fish in this
Lake I was planning on camping on a
nearby lake where I know there's fish
but after the sled got stuck all those
times I just you know grabbed the
nearest lake and camped on
it oh my mouth and lips are so dry it's
so cold outside there's almost no
humidity in the air just dries
everything out people who aren't used to
it will often get nose bleeds and really
bad chapped lips
got my dough from
yesterday ooo smells
great oo got some blueberry pie filling
we're going to put on our
bread yeah that looks pretty good to
me this is my reward for dealing with
the chainsaw and coming
back all
right pretty
day it is - 10° F I'm curious to see if
that chainsaw will
[Music]
start I got it starting but the Chain's
Frozen all right it was a bit of a
struggle but it got it going still got
that Summertime bar oil in it though and
that's not good I need to switch over to
wintertime Bar Oil let's make sure the
snow machine
[Music]
starts yeah that was a little bit rough
it's 11:00 in the morning and the sun's
just barely coming up the sun will peek
out over that mountain for about 2 hours
before it sets again I think I'm going
to grab the 22 and do a little bit of
hunting but I'm not going to do it here
I've seen absolutely no tracks in the
snow if you're a Tagan or a rabbit or a
moose the only thing you can eat are
Willows and there's no Willows growing
around here it's all black Spruce part
of that has to do with the lack of
sunlight and the type of ground we're on
so I need to get up on a hillside
somewhere out of this marshy lowland
area got a pretty good view of the
valley here I'm just looking for Willow
patches looks like there's some over
there that
way see these patches of Willows right
here that's what I'm looking for the
Moose have been coming along and biting
the tips off the Willows that's the part
you can eat is the tip so if you find a
spot where there's lots of tips low to
the ground you'll find rabbits and
Tagan you notice how the trees aren't
covered in as much snow as they were
over by the tent this is because we're
on the southern facing side of the
valley this side of the valley gets more
sunlight it gets warmer and that melts
the snow on the trees and it falls off
you're going to have more animals living
on this side of the valley and it's
going to be better
hunting I'm climbing up this Southern
facing mountain and you can see the
vegetation has changed a lot you got a
lot more Willows and alers and things
that birds and moose and rabbits can
actually eat and you can see that
there's moose track s
everywhere look at this is all boov all
boo woo I just want to go up a little
bit higher to where it opens up now I
think we got a good chance to see some
Taran I have to be really careful going
around these Trails one of the most
dangerous animals in Alaska is the moose
and they don't like walking in the deep
snow so they like to walk on the snow
machine Trail and if you surprise a
moose he'll kill you rather than get off
that trail Trail it's the number one way
people get attacked by Moose it's in the
winter time on Trails like this I just
got to take it easy around the corners
try not to surprise
anybody see
this that's caragan poop in the fall
their poop is purple cuz they eat
blueberries but in the winter time
they're living off the the tips of these
Willow branches and Alders and it makes
their poop look like
this but this is what we're looking for
on a clear sunny day like today the
Tagan are be on a southern facing slope
they're going to be basking in that
sunlight and they're usually in big
groups this time of year so there could
be like 20 to 100 birds in one flock
sometimes if you listen you can hear
them all right let's keep
looking
that's a Tagan right up there I could
hear one there's a Tagan right up there
tarmigan are really hard to spot they
turn white in the winter time so they're
very camouflaged all right let's go see
if we can find
them I can hear the tarmigan they're up
there for sure oh I just saw one oh yeah
there's like 20 or 30 right up there
we're going to
just walk go I heard those Tagan long
before I saw them you know a big group
of Tagan like that they're
noisy it's impossible to be stealthy in
the snow you make so much
noise these are all Tagan tracks right
there oh look at that there's there's
five six 7 8 N9 oh there's probably 30
of them whole flock just landed right up
there
that's where I got to
[Applause]
go a few minutes later well that didn't
go as
plan oh
jeez I think I'll go the rest of the way
on
foot
look at it just tons of
them this is the perfect weather for
Tagan hunting with all that strong
sunlight coming in at an angle you can
see those white birds on the snow from
way far away and because it's sunny and
there's no wind the birds will be out in
the open instead of hunkered down and
hiding when you have weather like this
the Tagan are always going to be higher
up on the mountains it's warmer the
higher up on the mountains you go on
Sunny calm days like
today that flock is way up that hill I
don't think they'll let me get close
enough to get a shot I think I'm better
off continuing down the trail and see if
I can run into some more
Tagan see that entire Hillside is
covered in tarmigan
tracks I don't hear
anything see is kind of goalie when the
wind is really blowing that's where you
go to look for Tagan but it's a nice day
today so they're not going to be there
they're going to be on the
Hills tell you what this has been fun
but the sun's starting to get low and
I'm really far from
Camp all these clouds just started
rolling in it makes every just kind of
look blah white makes it hard to see the
path and the ups and the downs and it
makes it really hard to hunt Tagan and
rabbit made it back before Sunset
yay oh we're getting a little low on
firewood time to go chop some
more tell you what I am hungry
I did not get lunch today I got brought
worse I love these
things my water's got lots of Pulp in
it oh it is so dry out I don't know if
you can see it but it's so dry that I'm
starting to get a little sore in the
corner of my
mouth just to use a little fat like this
butter that actually works really well
and it tastes good too all right all
right for dessert I've got some bread
pudding I mixed all the raw ingredients
together and vacuum sealed it and uh now
I'm just going to cook it in a pot of
boiling
water
that
woohoo I love white broths and mustard
that is so
good
oh oh that smells good it's got cinnamon
vanilla raisins in there there and uh I
got some leftover pie filling so that's
happening hot bread
pudding that was
good I'm going to sit here and listen to
an audio book and I'm going to go to bed
I will see you guys in the
morning oh good
morning oh slept a whole lot better last
night
Sun's starting to come up I left the can
of pie filling on the floor and it froze
last
night yeah well we'll thr that out no
problem it
is oh that looks good I'm
hungry that's good well this entire
camping trip has been a bit of a test
run for a much bigger camping trip I
want to do this winter and it's been a
good Shakedown run I sorted out the
problem with the chainsaw I need to do a
better job packing my gear into this
Leed and I got a little practice to help
me uh learn how not to get the snow
machine stuck and how to get it out when
I do but I think it's time to pack
up it's a little cold looks like it's
about a 11° fah
I've got to make sure the tent is warm
when I take it down there's any Frost or
snow in the joints of the poles when
they're cold they'll freeze together and
you can't get the poles apart so it's
best to get the tent nice and hot and
then take it down
quickly
[Music]
is
see this big puddle of water that's
where the stove was if I had have let
the tent cool this entire puddle would
have froze with the tent stuck inside it
I wouldn't have been able to get the
tent off the ice everything's just a
little bit harder in the cold and you
got to think ahead and plan for these
things it just it's just a
lot
got the freight sled loaded up just
warming myself up before I hit the trail
hasn't been an easy trip didn't quite
turn out the way I wanted but it was a
good
one
well that was a wild ride hopefully you
guys enjoyed it if you guys want to see
more Adventures from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe all right I'll see you guys in
two weeks if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching